in I've been sharing since this new
Council
I know
um yes so uh welcome everyone to the
first uh licensing Committee of the new
Council uh I just remind everyone to
press the like buttons on the
microphones uh just to make sure
everyone can hear and the recording can
pick up all your voices
um
so we'll go straight through to item one
apologies for absence
councilor Thomas with a council of Ford
substituting thank you very much
okay could I just say I need to go at
quarter 12 I have another meeting
because obviously being an hour later is
and I've got meetings this afternoon so
I can't miss the one at 12. okay sorry
about that fair enough yeah
um item two minutes of the previous
meeting
I think we're looking through and it is
possible for us to agree it so it should
go through
um the numbers at the top of the page so
page one
and page
two page three
on page four and anybody got any issues
in there
can I go for a proposal yep
excellent and we'll go to the votes and
we'll go for votes four on there
oh uh yes if you weren't on the actual
meeting you can't really have to abstain
so there's a few of us
against
an abstention
oh
yeah I'm staying yes
yes that's cool
thank you very much
um
action lists we've got nothing on that
have we
nothing to update with at the minute are
we looking for items to come forward
that'll be later in the forward yeah
forward okay cool
um Declaration of Interest so it should
own in the game by now um if there's an
item that comes up and you've got some
kind of interest you write down let us
know
um
item five great items of Team part one
and part two well we haven't got a part
two so that's easy enough uh uh item six
urgent has to be bought for permission
to chair and committee well I have
actually now got one uh going by our
training earlier
um Chris informed us that the licensing
act 2005 uh hasn't increased its fees
since 2005 and so I'm suggesting that we
actually write to our MP and kind of
make representation that we should be
looking to get those prices realigned to
be more reasonable because well was it
29 pound which we're never gonna
23. three pound for a personal license
I'm sure the hours for far more than
that we would probably never make money
on it so or well Breakeven I suppose um
so yeah I think we should make a
representation too
difficult if the committee is in
agreement with that I don't know if we
need an official vote
or
um
yeah and I think he said there's a um a
consultation going on at the minute as
well so it would help to fight that case
as well so
so if you've got a frozen secondary
should we go for uh well any anybody who
got a discussion on it or
no well I'll go to the vote and those
are in favor
and against
and abstentions
right that makes sense
cover Arch
um item seven the licensing act policy
review so
Chris if you want to
okay thank you chair
yes um the purpose of the report is to
review and update the authorities
current statement of Licensing policy
under Section Five of the licensing act
2003 the policy must be reviewed every
five years the new one's due to come
into effect in 2024 January 2024 so in
order to allow time for us to consult
bring it back to this committee and then
it needs to go to full Council for
approval as well in order to do that
um by January we need to start the
consultation process fairly soon
so I've attached the draft of the
current policy
and there's not many changes being
proposed since the last update in 2018
I will update the torrage area of
information statistics which is in the
1.4 we've got a new paragraph in 4.6 on
counter-terrorism which is some new
legislation it's going through
Parliament which will be a requirement
on on license holders that are holding
events and large numbers of gathering
and there's also we've added a new
paragraph on on drinking up time and
cooling down period in section 6.7 just
for further information for licensed
applicants
there's also been a few other amendments
minor amendments throughout the policy
which I've highlighted in the yellow
which is just updating things there is a
paragraph relating to some new
initiatives such as drink spiking the
prevention of drink spiking
um and protection of violence against
women as well as some new initiatives
that have been brought out so we propose
to add a bit more detail on those and
we'll expect
licensees to to comply with those
initiatives
other than that it's um
fairly minor changes so it's just really
asking the committee to approve the
consultation period it'll go out for
discussion and I'll bring it back to
this committee with any amendments that
are proposed as a result of the
consultation
Council the Pennington
just a couple of things
on that opening first paragraph below
the map on 1.4 I always struggle with
the fact that torrid's the 95 percent
authorities described as Green Space
I think it should be more descriptive of
our area because it does imply that
we're open for a space for wild parties
and things that may escape the situation
of the licensing committee so I wondered
if we could just put something slightly
different from that point of view and
then forward to 4.13
um
0.2
a little two
TDC local development framework ldf went
out and I think it's neither J joint
planning policy committee that should be
reading in there as well at 4.13
thank you
has anyone ever else got a
issue they want to raise with them
that discussion
there was just one bit I had picked up
on 4.3.2 which I chatted with Chris with
before just about the word in it because
it almost says that we're promoting
spiking drinks so it just needs a bit of
rejigging of the word because obviously
that's not the intention it was
of the document
um
but anything else on that
well I will
propose from the chair then that we
accept that
um is there a seconder
oh yeah we cancel the harder
and I go for a vote for
things a week nice and
and then we go to item eight the
consideration of thought plan
so
we've got a
nothing in there so far anything turned
yeah I've got a couple of things first
of all actually on the 22nd 26th of July
the next meeting I'm on annual leave
um
we haven't got any urgent business so we
could consider whether to cancel that
meeting unless any feed urgent does
um come up in the meantime
so I'll put that forward sick for
September we have had some
representation from the taxi trade
relating to our policy in respect of
vehicles and go into electric vehicles
or policy states that will look to go to
electric vehicles by 2030 they're a bit
concerned at that time scale is not
going to be achievable so I would like
to Brit I'm going to have a meeting with
the taxi liaison committee to discuss
that and see what their proposals are so
it is proposed to bring that to this
committee for discussion at the meeting
on the 6th of September
and then on the 18th of October meeting
we'll bring the licensing policy back to
consider the issues raising the
consultation so that's what I've got
proposed at the moment is over to the
committee if there's anything specific
they once brought to a future committee
and we can't we did at one point we used
to bring some statistics and business
reports to committees as whether
[Music]
um the committee would be interested in
receiving so um on things like how many
licenses we've issued and um
budget issues how much we've made and
what we haven't made and that sort of
thing where there's anything along those
lines the committee would be interested
in oh yeah over to the committee really
yeah councilor Pennington if you've got
anything you want to answer that I was
just uh interesting here as we commit
his form to this new Council wanted to
have asked that we mixed the daytime and
an evening meeting so that it gives a
fair chance for those who have uh work
commitments
um to attend meetings I just wondered if
you would consider doing alternate 10
and 6 30 Evening meetings I mean yeah I
mean I'm more than happy to do that
because I'm one of the ones who probably
be impacted them by that as well so you
know I'm more than happy to change it if
the rest of the committee is so minded
two seconds
it's potential those that we have
alternate meetings in that we go 10 and
6 30 you can choose which one you want
to go first
yeah that sounds quite amazing
well yeah
well yeah well we can go with six and
six five I mean particularly set on 6
30. but it's a gift chance for people
who are working to come home from work
um I I um and it balances you know it
attracts younger members to a council
because they're working members I think
it's all right for retired members of
the council but working members I think
uh has a different issue and I
which
uh any other things that we might want
to put on the forward plan I mean if you
can't think of anything right now don't
worry just feel free to email me anytime
and I'll you know we have a discussion
and we'll see what we can stick on there
right
now
cool so I'll look sir cancel that one
then
um if there's no other business I'll
close the meeting at whatever time it is
now
oh
please please share whoever whatever I
say to the things somebody I mean you're
saying there's like a two-month lead
line into people getting
a license or whatever if we cancel that
meeting and something comes up then what
happens that
is making a significant
difference I mean not that I want to
come and answer nothing I mean at what
point does it get canceled it closer to
the date
any any applications that need reviewer
held in a subcommittee so they're held
independent of the main licensing
committee so we would
it's only policy stuff that we bring
directly to this community
um I've only just yeah decisions
very good to bring to avoid
um do we want to discuss the
subcommittee
well if you could hang around after the
meeting um we'll close it uh
time 11 15.